احدث مقطع فيديو جدلا عبر شبكات التواصل
الاجتماعي يظهر فيه اب سعودي يقوم بتحضير
الحليب لطفل رضيع
ربما ما دفع هذا المقطع لتصدر تراند ووجود
هذا الاب وسط مجلس رجالي في احدى
المناسبات
والنقاشات حول المقطع البعض يرى ان تصرف
الرجل طبيعي جدا ولا ينقص شيئا من رجولته
في المقابل انتقد البعض الاب الشاب
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله الناس على الفيديو الاب الذي
يحضر الحليب لابنه في مجلس الرجال ما
تعليقكم على هذا المشهد
[موسيقى]
انا ما قد شفت في حياتي انه في اب مثل هذا
الاب ما شاء الله تبارك الله الله يحميهم
انه وقته ومجهوده وشغله يعني حتى في عز
انشغاله ماشاء الله معطي وقت وبيساعد
المراه في في هذا الوقت يعني صراحه قدر
هذا الشيء واتمنى من الجميع ان يشوف هذا
المشهد وياخذه بطريقه ايجابيه
يعني مو مهم المكان قد ما يهم الولد اللي
ما يبكي ويصيح هو يموت لا ما يهم المكان
في اي مكان كان الاول اخيرا الولد هذا
جيعان ولا يبغى يبكي ولا يسوي شيء فعلشان
كذا لازم وبيت السعاده الولد تصرف من اب
حكيم جدا وانا ااه الولد جالس يرضى بالمره
يعلمه يعني يغطي احتياجات الطفل ويجلس في
مجالس رجال من هو صغير
انه ممكن يصير معي هذا الموقف اكيد
[موسيقى]
شيء ممتاز جدا يعني بمثل عن اصوله الرجل
العربي عن التعامل مع الطفل والتعامل مع
ال ال العائله
اتوقع انه مثل عن تربيته وتربيه عائلته
الكريمه الطيبه
حنان الاب بشكل واضح جدا ويمكن تجزء من
المشاعر دائما ما بتبقاش ظاهره للمجتمع ان
الاب ممكن يظهر الحنيه دي ولكن كان تصرف
جميل وهمم فيديو يعني حاسس ان الواحد
مشتاق لاولاده يعني اب راح وحلوه كويس وما
فيش اي اختلاف يعني هو بيكسب ثقه ال همم
شيء جميل جدا
اهتمام من الام فقط
[موسيقى]
من زمان ينضم لنا الوالد حسن انما سيد حسن
اهلا بك منورنا شكرا على تواجدك معانا
وصباح العربيه يعني الفيديو الذي انتشر
انتشارا كبيرا وانت تحضر فيه الحليب لابنك
وسط مجلس رجالي اولا ما رايك بهذا التفاعل
كبير مع هذا الفيديو
من كميه التفاعل اللي صارت على المقطع
خصوصا مقطع كان بين اصدقائي يعني ما كان
المقطع
متوقع انه ينتشر بهذه الطريقه
المقطع كان بين اصدقاء انا حطيته في تيك
توك
وانتشر خذ انتشار ما اقدر السيطر عليه
يعني حتى كنت ناوي احذفه في البدايه لان
الصوره اللي اخذت على المقطع غلط
بس حسن يعني واضح عليك كثير مرتاح وانت
بتعد الحليب يعني كانه هيك مش اول مره
اسلوب حياه عندك انت من مناصريه مساعده
الزوجات وانه المراه والرجال واحد يعني في
تربيه الابناء
انا ما اعتقد ان الموضوع ما جالس اساعد
همم الزوجه وقاعد اساعد احد انا قاعد سعد
ما اسعدت احدانا غير ولديه
اصيله لفت ابويه حنونه لكن بعض الثاني
والقسم الثاني اعتبرها انها تقلل من
احترام المجلس الرجالي كيف ترد عليهم
[موسيقى]
مجتمعات تقلل من الاحترام احنا في مجتمعنا
الموضوع طبيعي جدا الواحد همم
يشربونه يمكن تحضير الحليب
هو اللي كان اييي مشهد غير مقلوب
وهو كان محضر حليب من البدايه وخلص ما
اقدر اروح الدجاج
وعلى العموم ما كان في وسط المجلس مثل ما
قلت لك في البدايه كان في نهايه المجلس
وكنا نحنا جالسين شباب مع بعض
سيدات ونساء اشاد بعملك يعني واتمنوا على
ازواجهم ان يكونوا مثلك فهذا عمل الابوي
وعمل كمان زوجي جميل حسن حسن قبل الفيديو
اللي ترند غير حسن بعد الفيديو التردد هل
في ناس التات فيك بالشارع تذكرت وجهك من
الفيديو
لاحظت نظرات من البعض
لما كنت طالع مع
الامارات كنت في مطعم لاحظت نظرات بس ما
في احد كلمني يعني او ما في احد قال لي اي
شيء
طيب حسن بعد الانتقادات وبعد التعليقات
اللي كانت على مواقع التواصل وبعد
الانتشار الكبير لاثار الجدل لهذا المقطع
هل انت مستعد مره ثانيه تاخذ ابنك معك على
المجلس رجالي وتحضر له الحليب يا حسن
ايه اكيد مستعده اخذه بس انه يعني ما بحضر
للحليب وبسوي له نفس الطريقه لانه ما
بيكون لافته الانذار ما بيكون لافت
للانذار يعني والولد له خصوصيه والولد لا
المفروض ما يكون بهالشكل الناس الطالع
يعني الموضوع كان طبيعي في البدايه الحين
الموضوع ما صار طبيعي فما افضل الناس
اصور وانا اسوي الحين يمكن اخذ معي اكيد
هو ولدي وانا ابيع على يمين على طول
احسن سؤال سريع واخيرا يعني كيف الطريقه
المثلى لتحضير الحليب اسرع طريقه
هذا بس هيك يعني ههه
الكل يعرف شلون
المعتقد ان الطريقه تخفى علي اي احد اي اب
في الدنيا سواء حجوله ده حليب في وقتنا
اوقات الام كانت تعبانه
ما لازم حتى العالم يستهجنه او يتفاجئه من
هيك مشهد لازم يكون هذا المشهد يعني يعمم
على كل اب لانه احنا بنحكي عن والدين يعني
بنفس المرتبه وما عملته يعني عمل فطري
ابوي جميل ولفت وانا عن نفسي حسن بحييك
على هذا الموقف الحنون يعني كان الزوجه او
الزوج لما يجوع الابن من واجبهم يحضرون
الاكل شكرا جزيلا حسن النمر حدثنا من
الدمام
اقول لك الحين احنا في وقت الام والاب
يتنصلام من مسؤولياتهم
يعتقد انها طموحاتهم اولويات ويعتقدون ان
اعمالهم اولويات
فلازم ااا كل واحد يلتفت للجانب اللي في
البيت
شوف لنا الموضوع بس للنساء او للخادمات في
النهايه هو ولدك يعني مو ولد الخادمه
بعد اذنك موجود
شكرا لك